Onyx logic is a place where you can
learn by doing
we combine theoretical knowledge and
understanding of biomedical data and
bioinformatics with practical examples
where you can apply what you have
learned and growing your ability to
start thinking creatively develop
independent projects and develop the
skills that you need to really be able
to be proficient with bioinformatics
this can be done in either one of two
ways you can either focus on the
biomedical research to develop research
and curiosity using data analysis
or you can be more focused on developing
coding skills and analytical thinking
these two tracks are divided by the type
of tool that we're going to prioritize
throughout the learning
if we're focused on the biomedical
research side we're going to primarily
rely
on a user-friendly interactive tool
called the t-bion for platform
there's little to no coding involved you
primarily assemble together pipelines or
sequences of steps to understand the
outcomes
on the other hand if you're more focused
on the data science or the skill based
approach you're going to prioritize
learning syntax different packages and
analytical methods implemented in coding
languages like R and python
so as you develop those coding skills
you will also be introduced to different
types of challenges and projects but
primarily that illustrate how specific
challenges are addressed using skills in
coding
first of all let's take a look at how
this could be broken down in a real
program
so let's say you are interested in
genomic data genomic data can be
Illustrated with a variety of different
projects one such example is source code
two where we compare sequences of the
source of 2 virus and we study how it
developed over time accumulating
mutations that led to different types of
outcomes
as you learn about what genomic data
looks like you are then prepared to
analyze genomic data
the idea is to have enough understanding
of what that data looks like to be able
to perform analysis and interpret it
biologically
so what would be the outcome
as the outcome the student should be
able to show differences between
multiple pathogenic strains and show how
maybe those map to the protein structure
of the virus that is responsible for the
viral entry into a cell
let's say you're interested in
transcriptomic data rna-seq
then you can take a project called the
cancer genome Atlas liver cancer project
where you will again understand the
context what is cancer what is gene
expression
how to compare sets of genes that are
differentially expressed then you will
take that data set from the cancer
genome Atlas that has patient data about
many different types of cancers and run
a pipeline which will produce an
interactive dashboard that will allow
you to explore different genes Pathways
and so as the outcome the student will
identify differences between Cancer
types or between wrist cancers that or
between risk factors that lead to liver
cancer for example hepatitis infection
or alcohol consumption and explain Gene
function responsible for those
differences
the Practical side of that program is
essentially
around activities that connect different
analysis steps together in what we call
an analytical pipeline
and to identify the right set of steps
for the right kind of data that answer a
specific research question
as a result the interactive outputs make
it easy to explore different types of
visuals and elements like genes their
expression Etc
which are commonly used in Publications
that kind of explain the research that
is being done
at the end of that the student
potentially can develop an independent
research project now developing a
research project independently takes
time so the first step is preparation
and giving an example and then after the
person is comfortable
understands the analysis can work
independently and has a reasonable
project proposal they can start
developing that independent project
before they do that we have a way to
track their activity
by assigning points to different steps
that they perform
and giving them program badges when they
interact with mentors around a specific
domain that they are most interested in
now some students decide not to work on
an independent project and that's why we
provide them with curated data sets and
initial steps that can help them get
started with a project across many
different types of data for example
cancer macrophages modeling cancer
Precision medicine the tumor
microenvironment malaria infection
potato resistant drought resistance and
deliver cancer and the cancer genome
Atlas for liver cancer risk
on the other hand some students want to
develop an independent research project
those kinds of students are motivated
primarily by working on an independent
project and they need the technical
support and the tools to be able to
identify data collect it and organize it
the way that they need to and then
perform the full analysis with an
emphasis on biological interpretation
here's an example of a high school
student who has been a part of a program
designed by the science coach
organization and the outcome was that
she was able to present this research
project at a science fair when she
presents that at the science fair she is
able to demonstrate that she was able to
address a research question and
interpret the research findings that she
herself
went through and analyzed
now some students are going to be more
focused on just completing coursework
and having skills that they feel enhance
their profile for example this student
at the Georgetown University Medical
School wanted to acquire skills in
machine learning applied to biomedical
data
others could not be could could be even
faculty members like you see here
faculty members that are learning
bioinformatics for the first time or
International students that come from a
variety of backgrounds and learn
throughout the course to just establish
their understanding
now if we talk about the data science or
the skill based approach here the idea
is a little bit different
obviously the same idea of developing a
project or using data to apply their
analytical thinking applies but the
focus is more on developing coding
skills to analyze biomedical data and
the outcome would be to demonstrate that
they have proficiency they understand
the syntax they know how to write code
they know how to make the code more
efficient and then they present what
they have done using those coding skills
to a mentor that can provide them with
feedback
so a lot more emphasis here on
understanding syntax of either r or
python
and using standard packages for data
wrangling visualization statistical
analysis and machine learning
again different types of data could be
used to do that and so the choice on
what kind of data can actually dictate
what kind of exercises they will perform
at the end the student will develop a
good understanding of how to take
different parts of code and organize
them into a jupyter notebook to
understand the syntax and be able to
edit that or maybe even write code
themselves and perform coding challenges
where they can test how well they
understand what they have done and
essentially produce an application or an
analysis notebook that they can
demonstrate to others
because coding
is something that many people learn we
also recommend developing a GitHub
profile as this student from the
Georgetown biomedical uh from the
Georgetown medical school did where you
can submit a repository of developed
code and that essentially introduces you
to the community of developers and data
scientists that are on that platform and
you are using examples from the projects
that you did throughout the program to
attach that to your outcome and to your
resume as well